We will now introduce a
new kinematic quantity
called angular momentum.
Angular momentum
will be very useful
when we describe the
rotation and objects.
In particular, how will
it be related to torque.
Now, what is angular momentum?
Suppose we have an
object of mass m.
And it's moving
in this direction.
And it has momentum p.
Remember, p equals mv.
Angular momentum is always
defined about some point.
So suppose we choose a
point s, and I wanted
to find the angular
momentum about
s due to this motion
of the object.
And the way it's defined is I'll
draw a vector from the point
s to where the object is.
And our definition of angular
momentum about s is equal--
this is three lines
for our definition--
it's the vector cross
product of the vector rs.
We have the vector p.
Now, how do we define the
direction of this vector?
Well, the way we do
that for any vector
product is we take
the two vectors
and we put them tail to tail.
So let's start off
by drawing the vector
rs in that direction.
And now when you
take a cross product,
we draw an arrow from the
first vector to the second one.
Remember, cross in vector
products are the same thing.
And now we want to
use our right hand
rule to get the direction
of the angular momentum.
So we curl our fingers.
And notice in this
case, it's pointing
into the plane of the figure.
And so the direction of the
angular momentum about s
is given into the plane of
the figure in our light board.
Now, we'll learn how to
calculate this cross product
in detail.
But suppose we have
our vectors which
are in a slightly
different arrangement
as seen in this figure here.
Well, what we see is with the
vector p and the vector rs,
we still use our right
hand rule to calculate
the direction of Ls.
Notice, whenever you have
a vector cross product,
that the vector Ls is
perpendicular to both
the vectors rs and is
perpendicular to the vector p.
And you can see in
both of these examples
that the angular momentum is
perpendicular to the plane
formed by the vectors rs and p.